america is reeling from its failed war
in afghanistan
it's the latest in a catalogue of
problems
from increasing social division and
political paralysis at home
to its seeming inability to lead a
global mission to tackle climate change
this against the backdrop of an
increasingly dominant china has led many
to believe america is losing its power
and standing in the world
u.s editor john prudeau joins washington
bureau chief james astill and senior
editor james bennett to discuss whether
these are genuine signs of a superpower
in decline
so so my question to you is
is america in decline and how do you go
about thinking about that question
and and i think the top line is that it
doesn't need to be america has has
blundered in its foreign policy
spectacularly in the past and come back
equally spectacularly there was a great
deal of declinism around in the mid late
70s after um the disaster in vietnam
and you know um a little more than a
decade later america had won the cold
war uh and was embarking on a period of
untrammeled unipolar um supremacy the
sources of america's you know enormous
strength
are still pretty much
intact
it has a young population
it has a flagging but still you know
rather impressive degree of economic
dynamism it has problems absolutely
and it has growing problems around
inequality
um some of its poor social indicators
around health and education
it uh it has a growing
climate crisis of its own i would
suggest that these are
considerable problems new problems but
america has faced considerable new
problems in the past in the past it has
had
an impressive ability
to change tack to improvise to problem
solve
america's
ability to get things wrong and then
reinvent itself is famously one of its
great qualities
and the thing that gives so many of us
pause right now in response to that
question is america in absolute decline
is that it's problem-solving ability um
has been
uh somewhat stagnant for a good while
and this is
of course a result of
the extreme political dysfunction that
we see at the federal level the
dysfunction is being exacerbated
by extremism on both sides but in
particular
far right of the republican party which
is now the balance of power in the
republican base which seems to be
turning against those problem-solving
institutions
in particular
american democracy itself hence um
the the the violent end to the trump uh
administration
the the so-called coup attempt um that
took place on capitol hill in january
james bennett same question to you but
perhaps let's stick with the foreign
policy piece of this for now rather than
talking about
domestic policy
i do think it's hard not to conclude
that
america
largely wasted its unipolar opportunity
over the last 30 years
in foreign policy that it find it found
itself somewhat to its surprise the
victor of the cold war in the early
1990s it was followed by this kind of
time of searching
in the clinton years to figure out what
america's proper role in the world
should be what it should do with all
this economic and military might and
there was some
uh
to and frowing about
liberal interventionism should we use it
be using america's power
to advance human rights
we didn't do so in rwanda where we could
have prevented a genocide we did do so
in probably from learning that lesson in
the balkans
and then came 911 and that in many ways
supplied the
orientation that um the leadership class
national security establishment was
looking for and clarified to many
people's minds what america's role in
the world should be and it argued very
much in favor of intervention
um
uh wherever we detected a threat
regardless of
sovereign boundaries and
we've now we're now at the end of really
this 20-year experiment in
power projection
and i can understand why it looks um
and can feel to an american
like decline because it involves retreat
i mean america is withdrawing from
it's it's very aggressive posture in the
world it's withdrawing from
um
uh afghanistan obviously and ending
combat operations in iraq there's been a
lot of
articles and think tank papers recently
about american overreach and foreign
policy if something like the rwandan
genocide were
underway now do you think america would
send troops to attempt to stop it
or do you think that the fatigue with
the 911 wars and with the deployment of
america's military and what now seem
like causes that aren't central to the
national interest
um would mean that america would revert
to its mid-90s posture the biden
administration is chocked full of former
advocates of liberal intervention biden
himself
voted for the iraq war voted for the
afghanistan war and was one of the
leading proponents of intervention
in bosnia intervention of some kind in
bosnia in the
mid 90s so um
that elite opinion i said i i suggest
has not sort of um
completely changed and become
isolationist has aligned itself with the
instinctive very very long-standing
public uh reluctance to see america
engage militarily in the world
and i think that you know for one thing
um a cataclysmic event another 911 or
some other you know perhaps unimaginable
um
catalyst of that nature would change
everything and america still has the
capabilities and then many of its
institutions especially the the
department of defense the instincts
to intervene militarily in the world so
i wouldn't rule that out i think we
should switch now to the domestic part
of american decline what longer term
investments can american leaders and
citizens make to turn around
um especially america's political and
social decline evidence for
america the the
continuing dynamism of the american
economy
um the power of immigrant contribution
to american life
the ability of americans to kind of
invent the future you know exhibit a for
that is probably now what's happened in
silicon valley
um over the last few decades and and
most recently the rise of these uh
social networks in the
u.s they are also now a huge source of
our political difficulty
and
how they
figure out what their responsibilities
are to american civil culture not just
american i think the global civic
culture and then how they
enforce those responsibilities is just a
huge question and we've seen
facebook
twitter
take some baby steps towards
acknowledging that responsibility and
trying to act on it but i don't i don't
pretend it's an easy
problem to solve it's a tremendous
difficulty and it's part of what is
i think injecting on a daily basis
venom into our political life poison
into our political discourse
and also just making it harder and
harder to do anything
about other sorts of institutional
problems the infrastructure bill
actually gives me a little bit of hope
because here's a problem that i think we
can all acknowledge
the us has had for some time
and
we actually have seen a major piece of
bipartisan legislation
um
thanks to really hard patient work by
some legislators you know make it
through and so that suggests it's
absolutely it's not actually impossible
how
much do you think
will be solved by these infrastructure
bills what's about to happen is is quite
a big deal isn't it yes it is um
uh i i i think the very much the
combination of of the infrastructure
bill
um passed as we expect um
in in the regular uh way with
the uh the more partisan uh budget bill
that the democrats want to
to throw
a couple or maybe even three trillion
dollars of spending into to to to
enforce you know in terms of soft
infrastructures um uh
social um uh
services et cetera and what they're
spending on hard infrastructure that
that combination um you know in
inefficient spending money not
necessarily the best way to reform and
improve america nonetheless
does does represent a lot of potential
progress and i i would signal um the
prospects for
um a massive roll out of climate related
infrastructure which in turn has the
potential to change the politics of of
climate change
in certain industries um and interest
groups and in the states perhaps even
more than at the national level that's a
big deal and after
you know these these decades of
essentially no major movement on climate
at the federal level in america that's
something to to to watch uh and be
optimistic about james b i'm going to
give what i think will probably be the
last word to you you began by talking
about this history of decliners in in
america is this just something cyclical
that's going on now how do you tell when
declinism is justified and and when it's
not
declinism does have a long and honorable
tradition in american history it really
does go right back to the massachusetts
bay colony
almost as soon as people arrived here
they were worried that
the settlers arrived that
that things were going to hell this does
not mean the decline is aren't
ultimately going to be right but um it
is it is part of our national character
and and arguably actually is
historically kind of a source of
strength the the parallels have been
drawn between this period and the and
the um
the late 19th century i think for very
good reason
in terms of the
degree of disorienting change that we've
experienced the capture of our politics
by
big money and big interest henry adams
was probably the most eloquent voice
then for american decline or global
decline you know i mean among the things
he cited as evidence of civilizational
decline decay was impressionism
so
you know he had a good case to be made
he had a good case we made he do some
data points that don't look so good in
retrospect but the point is that what
came out of that was again as in the 70s
a period of really tremendous reform and
rejuvenation the progressive era
and
you know the hopeful part of me
notwithstanding the degree of
political stasis that we're experiencing
you know clings to the idea that we can
pull that off again
you can read more of our coverage on
american power by clicking on the link
thanks very much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe